[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara Hellweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wir auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport heute
bodycams oder gar ein böllerverbot nach
den Angriffen auf Einsatzkräfte in der
Silvesternacht diskutieren Politik und
Gewerkschaften über Konsequenzen
Hoffnungsträger Lula Brasiliens neuer
Präsident steht für Arbeiterrechte und
Klimaschutz Deutschland gibt 35
Millionen Euro Hilfe für den Regenwald
und Deutschland im Darts Fieber schafft
Gabriel Clemens im WM Halbfinale die
nächste Sensation
[Musik]
die Gewalt gegen Sicherheitskräfte in
der Silvesternacht wühlt weiter auf die
Polizeigewerkschaft spricht von einem
widerwärtigen und in keiner Weise
nachvollziehbarem Verhalten
Innenministerin Fräser setzt auf
konsequente Bestrafung schärfere Gesetze
brauche es nicht tatsächlich drohen
schon jetzt bis zu fünf Jahren Haft an
Silvester waren vor allem in Berlin aber
auch in anderen Städten Polizisten und
Rettungskräfte angegriffen worden
Henriette de Maiziere
es sind diese verstörenden Bilder der
Silvesternacht die die Hauptstadt auch
an Tag 2 des neuen Jahres beschäftigen
wo das Feiern in Gewalt eskalierte wo
polizei und Rettungskräfte massiv
angegriffen wurden die
bundesinnenministerin teilt schriftlich
mit das ist ein Ausmaß an Gewalt das
fassungslos und wütend macht und es
zeigt eine Verrohung die konsequentes
Handeln erfordert den Sicherheitskräften
blieb teils nur der Rückzug ein Mann
wirft einen Feuerlöscher auf einen
Rettungswagen die Scheibe hält der
Stahlflasche stand die Polizei kann den
Werfer festnehmen Gewalt in bisher nicht
gekanntem Ausmaß die Polizei hatte genau
das befürchtet und Maßnahmen gefordert
es gab keinen generelles böllerverbot es
ist Aufgabe des Bundesministerium für
inneren hier das Sprengstoffgesetz zu
novellieren anzupacken dass es nicht
geschehen und die Länder insbesondere
Kommunen haben sich mit Verbotszonen
beholfen die mal besser mal schlechter
gewirkt haben allein in Berlin gab es
mehr als 100 Festnahmen auch in anderen
Städten Angriffe auf Rettungskräfte wer
die Täter sind darüber gibt es heute
keine konkreten Angaben wir haben jetzt
hier mit einem Teil der Bevölkerung zu
tun den die dem Staat und auch den
Vertretern des Staates distanziert
gegenüber stehen die nicht recht
erkennen wie wichtig es ist auch
bestimmte Normen in Bezug auf Gewalt
einzuhalten und in diesem Sinne werden
dann Feuerwehr Rettungskräfte und auch
Polizei als Repräsentanten gestartetes
angegriffen das neue Jahr kämpft mit
alten Problemen die Silvesternacht 2022
23 der Staat auch in die Diskussion wie
künftig Silvester gefeiert wird nicht
nur in Berlin sondern in ganz
Deutschland
woher kommt die Gewalt gegen Helfer
darüber spricht ZDF heute live unter
anderem mit einem konfliktforscher um 19
Uhr in der ZDF heute-app oder auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
wie viele Soldaten sterben im Krieg die
Wahrheit darüber herauszufinden ist
schwierig Verluste werden runtergespielt
oder zu hoch angesetzt je nachdem welche
Seite man fragt jetzt hat Russland hohe
Verluste eingeräumt bei einem
ukrainischen Angriff in der Region
Donezk 63 Soldaten sein ums Leben
gekommen dass die Zahlen noch viel höher
liegt behauptet die Ukraine Volker
DocCheck
hier ist kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen
das läuft dann auch die russischen
Besatzer nicht kurz nach Mitternacht
schlagen mehrere ukrainische Raketen ein
in der Berufsschule für Bauwesen in
markiefka sie wurde von den Russen als
kaserner genutzt 400 russische Soldaten
starben 300 sind verletzt sagt die
ukrainische Armee die moskauer-
Zerstörung eines temporären Aufmarsch
Punktes durch vier Raketen mit
hochexplosiven Sprengstoff wurden 63
russische Militärangehörige getötet
markievka in der Ostukraine das war vor
dem Krieg eine Stadt mit fast 350.000
Einwohnern sie liegt direkt neben der
Stadt dorniert die der umkämpften Region
ihren Namen gab ein schwerer Schlag für
die russischen Angreifer die auch heute
wieder Drohnen in die Hauptstadt Kiew
schickten 40 in einer Nacht die meisten
sollen abgefangen worden sein
Präsident selenski machte Bevölkerung
Mut beschwört zum Jahreswechsel die
Einheit des Landes die Russen haben
Angst das ist spürbar denn sie werden
verlieren Drohnen Raketen alles andere
wird ihnen nicht helfen denn wir
Ukrainer sind zusammen und sie sie sind
nur zusammen aus Angst
und während die Bilder von der
zerstörten Schule um die Welt gehen wird
das Militär in Moskau zunehmend Ziel der
Kritik ultra-nationale Blogger und auch
duma-abgeordnete werfen der Führung vor
dass viele Soldaten auf einer Stelle
solche Angriffe der Ukrainer provozieren
würden
unangemessen peinlich so die Kritik auf
Social Media an einem Silvester Video
von Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
aus der Union gibt sogar
rücktrittsförderungen es geht um eine
Neujahrsgruß auf lambrechts privatem
Instagram Account hier ein Ausschnitt
was war das für ein Jahr dieses Jahr
Herausforderungen gestellt mitten in
Europa Tod einbringen und damit
verbunden waren für mich ganz viele
besondere Eindrücke die ich gewinnen
konnte viele viele Begegnungen mit
interessanten toll
wenn ich was dazu
steht soweit der Ausschnitt aus dem
instagram-video der Ministerin schakunta
LAV energy in Berlin wie sehr schadet
ihr dieses Video also die Ministerin
stand ja schon seit längerem in der
Kritik von Kritikern heißt es immer
wieder sie interessiere sich nicht genug
für ihr Amt sie behebe Mängel bei der
Bundeswehr nicht schnell genug sie
setzte Strukturreformen bei der
Bundeswehr nicht entschieden genug um da
könnte man noch sagen das sind Kritiken
die sich Verteidigungsminister und
Ministerinnen traditionell anhören
müssen aber bei Kristin Lambrecht kommt
tatsächlich noch die kommunikative Ebene
dazu die wir eben auch in diesem Video
gesehen haben da hat sie in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder unglücklich
agiert und hat das Sport auf sich
gezogen z.B als sie beim Rufen nach
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine als erstes mal 5000 Helme als
Lieferung angekündigt hat das hat für
Sport und hohen und Kritik gesorgt aber
auch als Bilder von ihrem Sohn aus einem
Bundeswehr Hubschrauber aufgetaucht sind
in den sozialen Medien und jetzt eben
dieses Video noch oben darauf dass wenig
Feinfühligkeit zeigt die Union nimmt das
heute zum Anlass erneuten Rücktritt zu
fordern und auch den Bundeskanzler dazu
aufzufordern Christine Lambrecht aus dem
Amt zu entlassen und auffällig ist dass
es von SPD-Seite und aus dem Kanzleramt
heute keine Rückendeckung gegeben hat
für Christine Lamprechter hat sich
niemand nach vorne gewagt und gesagt
lass die Frau mal in Ruhe hat sie
verteidigt und hat versucht die Kritik
von ihr abzulenken also das war schon
ein auffälliger Moment heute hier in
Berlin das Christine Lambrecht mit dem
was sie sich da selbst eingebrockt hat
momentan sehr allein da steht
Einschätzung von natürlich vielen Dank
nach Brasilien dort steht der frisch
gekürte Präsident vor immensen
Herausforderungen die Wirtschaftslage im
größten Land Südamerikas ist
katastrophal Armut und sogar Hunger sind
verbreitet das Land ist tief gespalten
viele Hoffnungen ruhen jetzt auf Lula da
Silva bei seiner Amtseinführung feierten
ihn zehntausende christopherath
es ist der mit Spannung erwartete
Höhepunkt der Zeremonie wer würde Luisa
die präsidentenschärfe übergeben es sind
Vertreter jeder Menschen die aus Sicht
der neuen Regierung in den letzten
Jahren vernachlässigt wurden Arbeiter
Frauen Kinder schwarze indigene Menschen
mit Behinderung sie alle vereint auf der
Bühne ein emotionaler Moment einzigartig
in der Geschichte Brasiliens nachdem
sich der eigentlich für die Übergabe
zuständige Amtsvorgänger der extrem
rechte Ex-Präsident bolsonaro in die USA
abgesetzt hatte dessen von politischer
Spaltung geprägten Jahre will Luna
hinter sich lassen
[Applaus]
es ist Zeit dass wir wieder Verbindung
mit unseren Familien und Freunden
aufnehmen nachdem diese zerrissen wurden
von all der Hetze und den Lügen
Schluss mit Hass Fake News Waffen und
Bomben
zehntausende waren nach Brasilia gereist
und dabei zu sein vier Jahre lang hat
Ex-Präsident bolzenario die Axt angelegt
an demokratische Gepflogenheiten und
Institutionen und auch wenn der neue
Präsident Lula nicht unumstritten ist
und nur mit knapper Mehrheit gewählt
wurde wird er sich daran messen lassen
müssen Brasilien zu heilen
Lula verspricht vor allem mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit beim Schutz des
Regenwaldes stellte eine radikale
Kehrtwende in Aussicht und sind Kabinett
ist größer und diverser als zuvor auch
Europa reicht Brasilien wieder die Hand
Bundespräsident Steinmeier gratuliert
als einer der ersten
Deutschland will Lula da Silva
unterstützen auch beim Versuch die
truppenwälder wieder besser zu schützen
in Brasilien wurde unter der
Vorgängerregierung extrem viel Regenwald
vernichtet die Tropenwälder rund um den
Äquator sind nicht nur effektive
CO2-Speicher sie sind auch die
natürliche Klimaanlage die grüne Lunge
der Erde so wie Brasiliens riesiges
Amazonasgebiet
aus dem allgeblickt wird hier zum
Beispiel sichtbar wie sich der Mensch
Stück für Stück in nur vier Jahren in
den Urwald hinein gefressen hat
nein der Stadt Manaus im Amazonasgebiet
will sich Bundespräsident Steinmeier nun
selbst ein Bild machen Patricia
Wiedemeier ist dabei
es ist der dritte Tag seiner
Brasilienreise der Bundespräsident
unterwegs in den Regenwald naher Manaus
hier sieht es noch gut aus doch in
anderen Regionen wurden in den letzten
Jahren riesige Flächen abgeholzt
Steinmeier besucht ein Deutsch
brasilianisches Forschungsprojekt hier
wird gemessen überwacht erforscht wie
sich der Wald verändert durch die
Abholzung durch den Klimawandel
unter den vielen Vorhaben die wir uns
für das neue Jahr gemacht haben gehört
Klimaschutz und der Schutz der
Regenwälder ganz oben auf die
Tagesordnung und da sollte er auch nicht
herunter rutschen der Blick vom
sogenannten atto Tower zeigt die
Dimension der Regenwald am Amazonas ist
die grüne Lunge der Erde die Abholzung
hätte fatale Folgen das könnte bedeuten
dass in einigen Regionen mehr
regenschlaf fällt in anderen Regionen
das aber deutlich trockener wird und
deutlich trockener heißt das eben große
Teile das weil das dann hier dramatisch
austrocknenartige Wälder werden
Umweltministerin Lemke die mit
Steinmeier in Brasilien ist setzt auf
die neue Regierung
baue darauf dass wir mit der
brasilianischen Regierung eine neue
Allianz schmieden können für den Schutz
des Regenwaldes für die Naturschutz weil
wir die grüne Lunge der Erde brauchen 35
Millionen Euro will die Bundesregierung
jetzt freigeben für den Regenwald
Rettungsfonds Geld das bereits vorhanden
ist aber in den letzten vier Jahren
während der Amtszeit von Wolf Subaru
eingefroren war dazu viel Regenwald
abgeholzt wurde der neue brasilianische
Präsident Lula da Silva hat versprochen
bis 2030 die Abholzung zu beenden das
Geld schließt daher wieder weitere
Hilfen sind auch schon versprochen
höchstens zehn Jahre bleiben noch um den
Kipppunkt für den Regenwald zu
verhindern so die Experten hier
jetzt nach Rom dort standen die ersten
bereits in der Nacht Schlange um von
Benedikt dem 16 Abschied zu nehmen der
Leichnam des früheren deutschen Papstes
ist im Petersdom aufgebaut noch bis
Mittwochabend können Gläubige dort
hinkommen am Donnerstag wird Papst
franziskus die Begräbnisfeier für
Benedikt leiten anschließend wird er in
der Krypta des Petersdoms beigesetzt
dazu werden 50.000 Menschen erwartet
trotz Inflation und Energiekrise hat
sich die Lage auf dem deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt im vergangenen Jahr
verbessert noch nie gab es so viele
Erwerbstätige wie 2022 laut
Statistischen Bundesamt hatten 45,6
Millionen Menschen ihren Arbeitsort in
Deutschland das sind
589.000 mehr als im Vorjahr ein Plus von
1,3%. die Zahl der Erwerbslosen sank auf
1,3 Millionen das sind 209.000 weniger
als im Vorjahr ein Minus von 13,6%
schnell eine Pizza holen einen Burger
oder asiatisch essen zum Mitnehmen ist
praktisch aber es verursacht Massen an
Verpackungsmüll derzeit kommen in
Deutschland durch mitnahmeverpackungen
rund 770 Tonnen Müll zusammen pro Tag
Beispiel to go Becher allein davon
werden 140.000 weggeschmissen pro Stunde
und weil ein Weg auch für die
Restaurants einfacher ist als Mehrweg
steigt der Verbrauch sogar an neue
Regeln jetzt im neuen Jahr sollen das
Ändern Sven Ricken
in diesem Hamburger Restaurant gibt es
das Essen zu mitnehmen bereits in
solchen mehrwegbehältern der Kunde
scannt den QR-Code und Adapter dann 14
Tage Zeit um die Verpackung
zurückzugeben
die Verpackung die am meisten genutzt
wird ist unsere ganz einfache Schale
dann haben wir hier eine eine Sushi
Verpackung mit dem Boden aus Edelstahl
und dann haben wir hier noch unsere
Burger Verpackung für Burger und Pommes
Angebotspflicht heißt die Gastronomen
müssen zumindest ab einer Betriebsgröße
von 5 Mitarbeitern mehr victo-go
anbieten der Kunde muss es aber nicht
nutzen dabei kostet das Ausleihen bei
diesem Anbieter nur wenn die Behälter zu
spät oder gar nicht zurückkommen für den
Gastronomen ist Mehrweg meist sogar
günstiger als eine vergleichbare
Einwegverpackung to go wir müssen
natürlich auch dazu hinkommen dass dann
diese Mehrwegsysteme Standard werden das
Einweg teurer ist als Mehrweg das ist
auch noch nicht der Fall wir müssen dazu
kommen dass zum Beispiel vor Ort immer
in Mehrweg konsumiert werden muss am
Markt gibt es zahlreiche Anbieter mal
mit mal ohne Grund Gebühr mal zahlt der
Kunde fand mal ist die Ausleihzeit
kostenlos und das ist unübersichtlich
Hamburg wird daher mit sechs Anbietern
und würde gerne in Zukunft die
mehrwegnutzung verbindlich machen
Heimweg also ganz verbieten und
vielleicht ist eine angebotsplicht dann
ein guter erster Schritt man sollte dann
aber vielleicht auch nicht lange warten
um dann am Ende dann auch irgendwann mal
zu verbindlichen Dingen zu kommen zumal
ist derzeit zwei Hintertüren gibt die
Betriebe können eigene Behälter anbieten
und einen beliebig hohen pfandpreis
verlangen außerdem kann die
Angebotspflicht mit Papier und
Pappverpackungen umgangen werden nur ein
erster Schritt also in Richtung
kompletter Müllvermeidung beim Essen to
go
im bayerischen Ruhpolding haben
Winterspiele begonnen die mehr sind als
ein sportliches Ereignis denn ausrichter
ist der jüdische Sportverband makabi
Deutschland mit besonderer Geschichte
diese Postkarte zeugt vom ersten
jüdischen Sportverein in Deutschland
1898 in Berlin unter deutscher Leitung
wurde 1921 der weltsportverband
gegründet mit makabiaden ähnlich den
Olympischen Spielen die Nazis machten
jüdisches Sportleben hierzulande
unmöglich und jetzt erstmals in
Deutschland die Wintergames Jutta
sonnewald
sie sind aus aller Welt ins bayerische
Ruhpolding gekommen jüdische
Sportlerinnen und Sportler feiern
gemeinsam die Eröffnung der makabi
Winterspiele die ersten in Deutschland
die ersten seit 87 Jahren
[Applaus]
bei anderen jüdischen Traditionen etwas
das vor dem Krieg sehr aktiv war wird
jetzt wiederbelebt
wir haben viele Wettbewerbe in den USA
aber nichts ausdrückliches für uns
jüdische Sportler es ist sehr aufregend
an den ersten makabi Winterspielen
teilzunehmen ich persönlich darf jetzt
auch für Israel teilnehmen hier in den
Sportarten und Israel gab es in 1936
noch gar nicht also ich glaube auch in
dieser Hinsicht dieses für uns
historisch die letzten makabi
Winterspiele fanden 1936 in der
ehemaligen Tschechoslowakei statt damals
nahmen 2000 Athleten aus 12 Nationen
teil nach Ruhpolding sind etwa 400
Sportlerinnen und Sportler gekommen
natürlich geht es auch hier um den
Wettkampf aber auch darum Vorurteile ab
und Brücken aufzubauen
Deutschland ist heutzutage ein freies
und demokratisches Land und freut sich
darüber dass endlich mal die das
syrische Leben auch in diesem Bereich
sichtbar ist was er in den früheren
Zeiten nicht der Fall war mangels Schnee
wird ab morgen Biathlon und Langlauf im
benachbarten Reit im Winkel ausgetragen
Alpinski und Snowboarding in Kitzbühel
wenigstens die Eishalle in Ruhpolding
bleibt eine sichere Bank mit den
jüdischen Winterspielen in Deutschland
wird eine Tradition wiederbelebt und
zugleich ein Zeichen gesetzt gegen
Rassismus und Antisemitismus
[Musik]
Zeichen setzt auch ein deutscher bei der
Darts WM in London
Gabriel Klemens kaum aufzuhalten
allerdings ja der tritt gleich als
erster Deutscher in der
Turniergeschichte im Halbfinale an ja
und wenn the German giant wie in die
Fans nennen so spielt wie gestern Abend
beim Sensation Sieg gegen den
Weltranglisten ersten German price das
ist alles möglich
neues Jahr neues Glück neue Geschichten
Gabriel Clemens trennen bei der Darts WM
2 Spiele vom Titel im Viertelfinale
konnte selbst German price nicht mit dem
Saarländer mithalten Preis gewinnt zwar
Satz 1 dann aber dreht Clemens auf die
nächsten drei Sätze gehen an den
deutschen drei zu Einsatzführung Clemens
Favorit Preis wirkt angeschlagen denn er
spielt im fünften Satz mit Kopfhörern
genervt von den Berufen der Zuschauer
das gab's noch nie
ich war selbst ein bisschen überrascht
aber habe dann einfach gedacht komm
jetzt den Satz musst du unbedingt jetzt
gewinnen und das gelingt Clemens tut
sich Satz 5 und im entscheidenden
letzten Satz trifft sein erster
matchstart warum soll ich jetzt nicht
jeden schlagen also ich brauche vor
keinem mich vor keinem zu verstecken
deutlich sein Sieg gegen Preis im
Halbfinale heute Abend geht's gegen
Vorjahresfinalist Michael Smith
Brasilien nimmt Abschied von seiner
Fußballlegende Pilli am Vormittag
öffneten sich unter Applaus und PD rufen
die Stadion Türen seines
Lieblingsvereins FC Santos dort ist der
einbalsamierte Leichname des dreifachen
fußballweltmeisters heute aufgebaut
tausende Fans können so ihrem Idol die
letzte Ehre erweisen und zur Totenwache
wird auch Brasilien Staatspräsident Luna
erwartet morgen dann die Beisetzung im
Familienkreis übrigens im 9 Stock eines
Friedhof Hochhauses mit Blick auf dieses
schöne Stadion des FC santanders
andere Sitten ab morgen wird es etwas
kühler die Details zum Wetter hat gleich
Christa Orban das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka um 21 Uhr
wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend ja es war
einfach ein irrsinnig milder
Jahreswechsel auch bei unseren
europäischen Nachbarn nur zum Beispiel
in Dänemark in den Niederlanden in
Lichtenstein in Polen Tschechien und
Litauen wurden ebenfalls unzählige neue
Rekorde aufgestellt teilweise auch
unglaublich deutlich in dieser Woche
wird es jetzt aber überall Kühler doch
der temperaturforscher Film zeigt uns
ist bleibt immer noch zu mild für Januar
immerhin die Winterkälte hat sich jetzt
in Sibirien angesammelt und rückt uns
damit etwas näher heute Nacht dann noch
einstellige Werte zwischen zwei und acht
Grad dazu erreicht eine Kaltfront die
Alpen hier dann etwas Regen der Wind
lässt aber weiter nach und wird nur noch
an den Küsten lebhaft sonst gibt es
viele Wolken einige Schauer in der Mitte
des Landes und die Reste davon haben wir
dann auch noch morgen Vormittag zwischen
dem Allgäu und dem Berchtesgadener Land
regnet es auch noch etwas weiter
nachmittags lässt der Regen dort
allerdings nach allerdings kommen von
Nordwesten im Tagesverlauf neue Wolken
die spätestens am Abend Regen bringen
die Werte der Temperatur dazu an der
Ostsee 6 Grad am Oberrhein 12 Grad und
das sind auch die Temperaturen mit denen
es im Rest der Woche weitergeht dazu
wird es wieder richtig stürmisch und vor
allem im Norden regnerisch tschüss